so ich habe gesagt ich werde die Laune
macht jetzt aber nicht weil weil immer
hat man lässt sich nicht die Laune
verderben auch durch das Auftaktspiel
nicht doch
ganz erheblich also wenn man sie sagen
zumindest lasst mir meinen Fußball lass
die Politik raus vom Spielfeld das ist
ihre Kamera das ist ihre Zeit das ist
ihr Thema
sie haben sicherlich alle gestern die
Bilder gesehen vor dem Spiel die
deutsche Mannschaft mit der Hand vor dem
Bund so saß ich nach dem der
Schiedsrichter das Spiel abgepfiffen
hatte nämlich fassungslos dass ich eine
deutsche Nationalmannschaft wieder
einmal nach 70 Minuten ordentlichen bis
guten Spiel einigen torschossen die sie
nicht genutzt hatten aber sie führten in
den letzten 15 Minuten noch die Butter
vom Brot nehmen lassen
und da war meine erste Idee vielleicht
lag sie doch an diesen Nebengeräuschen
die sich seit Wochen und Monaten und
diese WM drehen und von der die Spieler
natürlich mitbekommen und dann habe ich
mich gefragt ist es wirklich sinnvoll
und richtig
Fußballspieler die ihr großes Ziel
nämlich die Teilnahme an einer
Weltmeisterschaft dazu zu den mit
Favoriten gehören
angehen plötzlich mit politischen Dingen
zu überladen zu überfrachten zu beladen
wie kann ich erwarten dass ein
18-Jähriger der es jetzt 18 geworden
während der WM mukoko oder ein
19-jähriger wie schon mal musikaler oder
ein 20-jähriger wie adelemi Haltung
zeigen oder Zeichen setzen die fahren zu
einer Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft das ist
keine
haltungsweltmeisterschaft das ist auch
keine weh im WM im Zeichen setzen dafür
sind Funktionäre da dafür sind Verbände
da dafür sind Organisationen wie eines
der Internet national
Menschenrechtsorganisationen zuständig
aber nicht Fußballspieler und warum
machen wir einen solchen Firlefanz
Bekenntnis eine Binde eine Waschlappen
großen Binde soll plötzlich Katar und
die Welt verändern ja wo sind wir den
Wolke Gesellschaft lasst mich die
genießen lass die Fußball spielen wenn
es nicht zu spät ist weil sonst haben
wir Pech und am Samstag am Sonntagabend
sind sie raus
also das war eine leidenschaftliche Rede
aber
macht es sich der Herr hat man dann ein
bisschen zu einfach Nein macht er sich
nicht denn ich bin der Meinung Schuss
dabei bei der einen leisten das sind
Fußballer und die sind da sind wir in
Auftrag ist tot zu schießen und dann
nicht darauf vorbereitet ich finde es
ist im Prinzip was jetzt passiert ist
der größte anzunehmende go das ist so
ein bisschen schwanger nicht gibt gibt's
auch nicht ein bisschen Menschenrechte
ja ich gehe dann auf dem 10 Meter Turm
überlege mir was anderes und gehe wieder
runter so ist das das heißt also mit
dieses hohe Wert der Menschenrechte und
zurecht wird gegen zuständigen Katar
aber das ist nicht unbedingt die Aufgabe
derer die dahin gefahren sind das heißt
also hier wurde etwas mit etwas
überfrachtet und dann viel auf sich
selbst zurück nämlich den Fußball und
dann sind die völlig bedepperter im
gesamten Anliegen wurde schwerer Schaden
zugefügt und auch dem deutschen Fußball
schuld daran sind die die zum einen dass
die Spieler dorthin vergeben haben in
Kenntnis der Sachlage zweitens ein Teil
der deutschen Medien die das Druck
gehabt haben wie das 14 Tage so üblich
ist dann wird sich kein Mensch dran auch
stören in Katar von den verhüllten
scheiß und den anderen und den Darm
niemand wird dort auch nur einen PIP
sich dafür interessieren 3,5 Milliarden
Menschen schauen diese
Fußballweltmeisterschaften die damals im
Ernst dass davon auch nur zwei drei
Prozent gerührt sind mal ganz ehrlich
ich bin Realist und was mich besonders
stört ist diese Unausgewogenheit wo
waren denn die Damen und Herren
Demonstranten und Menschenrechtsgruppen
in Moskau wo waren Sie denn in Peking da
sehe ich sie nicht demonstrieren damit
es kostet nämlich zu viel ja das darf
mein Mann ihn noch mehr Mann im Spiel
und die anderen haben Power wir haben
ein unaufrichtige Menschenrechtspolitik
durch die Bank heute zum Beispiel hat
das russische Parlament die du mal heute
ein Gesetzespaket verabschiedet gegen
Lesben und Schwule und Trans und alles
mögliche bereit hatte Gesetze die ihren
strafrechtlich verfolgt wo sind denn die
Leute vor der russischen Botschaften die
Russen bom zur Zeit ein Land in die
Steinzeit zurück bilden im Winter wo
sind denn die linksparteifreunde die ich
habe schon mehrfach vor der russischen
Botschaften die hinter diesem russischen
Vorgehen stehen und das Decken und den
Ukrainer nicht helfen wollen da beginnt
doch mal muss ich Ihnen sagen verloben
bis zum geht nicht mehr äh ist ja wenn
bei uns stellen sich mal vor die Kreisen
ab und alles wieder vorbei wir haben nie
tubewegung wir haben wo Bewegung dann
kommt irgendwie wieder was anderes ja
gerade was hier in ist in der Pizzeria
der veröffentlichten Meinung wird dann
hochgepeitscht ich muss allerdings
dafür
deswegen bin ich gemeint mein Thema
jetzt alles gut
klar die Zeitung die unter dem gleichen
Titel
veröffentlicht wird wie diese Sendung
nämlich die Bild ich denke mir was ist
denn eigentlich mit dieser
Sportredaktion los also heute aufmachen
das Bild und dann kommt Frau Feser mit
dieser eigenen Aktion mit dem One Love
auf einem das waren die Themen Aufmacher
SPORT BILD ich sag Jungs und die fanden
das auch gut seid ihr denn eigentlich da
macht mal das was mit dieser Mannschaft
passiert ist warum das passiert ist
Wasser das machen die auch aber vorneweg
ist plötzlich diese ganze Diskussion
auch im Sportteil der Bild von einer
dennoch lassen sie uns einmal beim Thema
bleiben die Homophobie dort werden
Schule lesbische Menschen umgebracht
kann man das trennen kann man sagen hier
wird gekuscheltiere kann man sagen dass
man das vom Spielfeld fernhalten soll
also wer hat man sagt das sind Fußball
sein stimmen Sie dazu
ich glaube man muss es differenziert
sehen ich glaube das Hauptproblem ist
die FIFA und die Vergabe nach Katarina
das ist das Hauptproblem weil auch
natürlich katarpolitische Interessen
damit verfolgt also weil die
interessieren sich ja nicht für Fußball
da wird auch nicht Fußball gespielt in
dem Land da gab es glaube ich nicht mal
einen Fußballplatz in dem Land sondern
das ist ein politisches Interesse was
dahinter steht und die FIFA dieses
Politik Spiel mitgemacht so ich weil ich
kann von 18 oder 19-Jährigen nicht
erwarten dass sie
Botschafter für politische Botschaften
werden das kann ich tatsächlich nicht
erwarten nichtsdestotrotz kann man das
erwarten warum nicht mit 18 19 da kann
man wählen also das kann jeder für sich
entscheiden aber man kann es nicht von
ihnen erwarten so ich erwarte von keinem
18 oder 19-Jährigen dass er irgendwie
sich über sich schon irgendwie völlig
sicher ist wo er in der politisch steht
für 16-Jährige ja das ist aber was
anderes ob ich Öffentlichkeit reden ja
Haltung bzw
okay weiter
das ist ja wirklich ein Unterschied
aber doch wichtig ist und und deswegen
finde ich ist das Hauptproblem
tatsächlich die FIFA und die Vergabe und
nichtsdestotrotz ist auch jeder der auf
dem Fußballfeld steht oder am Rand als
Trainer oder als Trainerin hat natürlich
auch eine Haltung und eine Verantwortung
für das was da passiert insofern hätte
ich das gut gefunden wenn dir die
Armbinden einfach nicht
doch
zum Fußballspiel die Verantwortung der
Präsident des DFB aber entscheidend
trotzdem es sind keine fußballautomaten
die da auf dem Platz stehen sondern es
sind individieren aber es gibt doch eine
Sache
stehen dass sie sich selber entscheiden
können was sie sich anziehen ich will
einmal kurz insofern
glaube ich es geht hier nicht um Vogue
oder nicht Vogue sondern es geht darum
dass wir eine
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in ein Land
vergeben worden ist was mit von gar
nichts zu tun hat
Korruption im Spiel ist dass diese ganze
FIFA
aber der der entscheidende der
entscheidende Punkt ist wieder dazu das
fußball ist das ist
Mensch
ich weiß das doch für Leute die reden ja
schon die ganze Zeit
das größte Alter bei sowas mitzumachen
das ist doch ganz klar
nächste Woche fahren
jetzt immer Wasser nachfüllen und alle
kurz mal runter kochen und eine ganz
kurze Pause machen